So, give me a callback at your earliest convenience...
...as I'd love to set something up.
I think we would be of great help to you.
Okay, talk soon.
Thanks. Bye.
Here we go.
How is your morning shaping up so far?
Great. Have some pretty solid leads.
Been working on some clients that I met at the Rosenberg mixer last week.
They seem pretty promising.
Well, that's just great.
You know, I think this is gonna be a fantastic new venture for us.
I was reading in the Journal this morning...
...how the government put 16 thousand new agents out...
...just to enforce this one single piece of legislature.
So, I'd say that the harvest is gonna be pretty plentiful.
Sounds like dollar signs to me.
Any new business on your end?
I've been doing some innovative marketing...
...in some of the local businesses in the area...
...and, I gotta tell you, I think I've turned a few heads.
Guerrilla-style marketing.
Nice.
Always effective.
Plus with this new software, I think this'll be a great season.
You know, I think you're right.
So now we just...
I guess we just wait, huh?